i have a piecewise defined function here
and my goal is to figure out its domain
and its range so first let's think about
the domain and just as a bit of review
the domain is the set of all inputs for
which our function is defined and over
here our input variable is x so you
could think about it's a set of all the
values that x can take on and actually
have this function be defined actually
be able to figure out what f of x is
and when we look at this we see okay if
0 is less than x is less than or equal
to 2 we're in this clause as x crosses 2
and is greater than 2 we follow this
clause and as we approach 6 but right
when we get to 6 we fall into this
clause right over here all the way up to
and including 11. but if we get larger
than 11 the function is no longer
defined i don't know which of these to
use and if we're at 0 or less the
function is no longer defined as well so
in order for this to be defined x has to
be greater than 0 or we have to say 0 is
less than x and you see that part right
over there
and x has to be less than or equal to 11
and x has to be less than or equal to
11. it's defined for everything in
between as we as we once again as we as
we get to 2 we're here as we cross 2
between 2 and 6 we're here and at 6 from
6 to 11 we're over here
so we're defined for all real numbers in
this interval so our domain is actually
let me write this all
all
real values
are all
real we all real values
maybe all right let me write that way
all real values such that
such
that 0 is less than x is less than or
equal to 11.
so now let's think about the range
let's think about the range of this
piecewise defined function and that's
the set of all values that this function
can actually take on
and this one is is maybe deceptively
simple because there's only three values
that this function can take on it can
take on f of x can be equal to one it
can be equal to five or it could be
equal to negative seven
so the range here we could say that f of
x
needs to be a member of this is just a
fancy mathy symbol to say this is a
member of
the set
1
5
negative 7. f x is going to take is
going to take on one of these three
values another way to say it is that f
of x
is going to be equal to one five
or negative seven this is maybe a little
less pronoun a little a a a less a less
mathy way a less precise way of saying
the same thing but one way or another f
x can only take on one of these three
values